What's wrong with Mi? It's already over. I can't believe it, Mr. Lott.
No problem, Ray player defense.
Well, this is it. Ah, Ray player counterattack.
If he gets trapped, it's over. I won't
eat the same
thing twice. I'm so cool, Claire-sama. As expected, I
like young ladies who are skilled in both literature and martial arts. Now, Claire-sama, what
can you show us next?  Well,
don't get carried away. I never
thought I'd end up using this on a commoner. That's
France's emblem magic. The
current one is a warning. As you can see, it's the same magic as before.
It's an order of magnitude more powerful. Even I can't hit it that many times. Once you know that, surrender. It
's impossible to dodge it after seeing it. That's right. It's
frustrating after all, so I'm going to go for the win.
[Music]  ]
Clare-sama, wait a minute. Even with such plain
magic, the
magic is still falling.
Claire-sama can escape, but
don't move there. Wait,
now, use your magic to widen the hole and give up.
Claire-sama, what are you talking about?  Did you
forget that Rei is a dual caster?
You've
never used water attribute magic, which is effective against your fire attribute. You were being
lenient, Claire-
sama.  I
'm sorry, but I
'll stop the referee until the winner, Ray.